loads of russia sputnik v rolling into
hungary
the first fourteen thousand of some two
million doses
ordered the distribution of vaccines in
the european union
just not quick enough for hungary the
faster we vaccinate the weakest segments
of hungarian society the quicker we can
lift restrictions on public life
sputnik v was the first vaccine
developed to fight covet 19.
russia began vaccinating people with it
last summer
even though clinical trials were
underway hungary's emergency bylaws gave
the vaccine the green light
that's because sputnik fee has already
been administered
at least a million times without any
serious side effects
so hungary has decided to sidestep the
eu's common procurement policy this
only applies in very strict conditions
conditions under very specific
criteria and then the member state is
liable russia is promising enough of its
vaccine for 700 million people
sputnik v is more than 91 effective
according to a study published on
tuesday in the medical journal the
lancet
the raw data used in the study has not
yet been released
unfortunately that's exactly what the
european medicines agency needs
when the agency gets the data in the
proper form so they can check it
as with other manufacturers then i can't
see why the vaccine can't be approved in
europe
germany's chancellor agrees
every vaccine is welcome but only those
that supply the necessary data and are
approved by the ema
will be accepted it's said the virus
knows no boundaries if the data is
correct that can also apply to vaccines
there was angela mackel there in that
report speaking on prime
time german tv tuesday evening the
chancellor gave a wide-ranging interview
focusing on
the many concerns surrounding the
coronavirus pandemic
well let's bring in dw's chief political
correspondent melinda crane
well linda on the sputnik v shot mecca
was
clear that no vaccine will be allowed in
germany until it's been
approved by the european medicine agency
how does she
justify that when germany is facing a
vaccine
shortage well this is
the policy european multilateralism that
the chancellor has set
for germany it's the policy that she
quite adamantly
defended at her government's vaccine
summit uh
on monday and it's a policy that
reflects her deeply
held conviction that germany must act
in common with europe and let me just uh
remind all of us that europe in fact
comprises the first
chapter in this government's coalition
agreement
germany has in the past of course
sometimes gone
its own way under chancellor mackel uh
getting out of nuclear energy for
example after fukushima
or uh or its decision to take in
migrants in the summer of 2015
and frankly the repercussions of those
decisions
were very problematic for this country
also there is a pragmatic
consideration here the fact is that even
with quick
approval the russian vaccine would not
be
available in europe until the second
quarter of this year
and as we did hear from the government
on monday
the supply shortages we're currently
seeing are going to ease
anyway in the second quarter the
chancellor says even with all the
supplies
that are currently uh in the pipeline
definitely germany will be able to meet
its goal of vaccinating everybody by the
end of the summer
well this is a rather awkward moment for
eu russian relations isn't it
diplomatically you've got the eu on the
one hand condemning
russia for his treatment of alexei
navalny and on the other hand
looking longingly at this vaccine
possibility
sputnik v absolutely it's a very
complicated moment to be doing business
with russia but i do think cooperation
on the vaccine can be distinguished from
other forms of business relations that
directly benefit
the elites associated with president
putin
politicians from across the political
spectrum here in germany
are saying that they see no obstacles to
using
the russian vaccine and to co-producing
it here in europe
i think the bigger question right now is
whether germany should be continuing to
pursue a project like the north stream
gas pipeline deal
which does benefit those russian elites
and which is absolutely opposed by a
number of other european partners
and by the new u.s administration and
just uh finally a word about hungary
which uh
it's decided to break ranks with its
european
partners and go ahead and use the
sputnik v
vaccine what is what does that mean
well hungary is basically exactly the
other side of the coin from
uh miracle's determination to proceed
multilaterally
hungary is uh going it alone on a number
of different fronts
including uh its undermining
of rule of law and democracy uh
domestically
and we're also seeing hungary now
ordering uh
the chinese vaccine from the chinese
company
sino farm so i think what we're
absolutely seeing is hungary's
commitment
uh to doing a hungary first type
approach
exactly what the chancellor doesn't want
welinda thank you so much uh dw's chief
political correspondent melinda crane
liana fix from the kerber foundation
here in berlin is still with us
uh leanne french president emmanuel
macron says politics should not be an
obstacle when it comes to possible
vaccines against the coronavirus german
chancellor mackel says she would be open
to the russian vaccine once approved by
the ema
but many people are wary what's your
opinion is there good reason to trust
russia with this vaccine
i think there was reason to be wary when
russia used the vaccine without the
third
phase which was necessary which is from
a clinical perspective necessary now
that we have independently confirmed
results
i think this is indeed good news and
angela merkel has been
one of the first to talking to the
russian president and discussing
um possibilities for using the vaccine
in europe and let us remind
them and let me also remind us that in
russia there was also a lot of
skepticism towards
sputnik so that was a problem that was
made
by by moscow itself it was not
transparent enough from the beginning it
and when it comes to the numbers it
still is not transparent enough
but the fact that we have an
independently confirmed
study about the effectiveness
effectiveness of the vaccination
is really good news thank you very much
for your insights that was liana fix a
russian analyst
at the kerber foundation here in berlin
thank you